hi my name's russell fickling i'm going
to take you through
um a couple of videos around using the
new customer portal
um
the first is going to focus on identity
logging in and so on
so what you're looking at here is the
the landing page for the portal um you
can see across the top um we've got a
menu we've got contact we've got search
those are all um
an exact copy of what you see in your
main website the new website
so that's just to provide a consistency
of of experience for users as they
switch between
but first area i'm going to focus on is
this login link at the top here and
you'll also see the same login link in
the website
so if i click login
i'm presented with a range of options
the first on the left is
logging in with an email and password
but on the right hand side we've also
got options
to use social providers so we've got
google microsoft and facebook and these
might change over time as
different
options
become more more more or less popular
now this is um a login screen so this
assumes that the user is already signed
up if they haven't signed up previously
then we've got down the bottom here it
says don't have an account then sign up
here
so what i'm going to do is
register for a new account for the first
time so i click sign up here
again i've got the option of either
email or password
in this case i have to put my password
in twice because it's the first time
we're capturing it
or we can sign up using
one of the social providers if for
example i wanted to use my facebook
login
i click sign up with facebook and then
i'm bounced to the facebook page to sign
in
same with the other providers but if i
was already logged into facebook in my
browser
then it would automatically sign me in
and redirect me back and that's really
the advantage
of these social providers is that
you don't have to often type in
your login and password because your
browser's already signed in particularly
with google if you're using gmail
um
and so on
um however i'm going to create a
login with
uh with an email address so
i'm just going to use
um
my gmail account with an alias if you
use the plus sign it's a
it's an alias
um
i'll just make up a unique email address
and then i'm entering my password now
the password
has various rules around the complexity
that you need to
provide so as i type
um i'm going to tab out of the first
password it evaluates me against those
rules so i've got minimum mate
characters i can't use the word password
if they've at least one digit one
uppercase
um and no more two than two characters
the same in a row so this is these are
sort of standard rules um based on best
practice
um at the moment they might evolve over
time but you'll get that feedback um to
the user straight away one that's
crossed there is that
that i haven't confirmed it yet so
and saying they don't match now if for
example i um
[Music]
didn't have
some of the rules then they'll just go
red or green as i type so
quite easy for users to see
how they're
matching
um so i've managed to put same password
in twice um we've got links to in terms
of use and privacy they will redirect to
your to your website just um
providing whatever terms you want to add
so having entered that i click sign up
and
when you sign up for the first time
[Music]
you put in an email address we want to
know that the person using that email
address does actually own it they're not
using someone else's email address so
what we do is we send an email
to
the email address they've entered with a
particular code in it
so
i'm just going to
drag in my gmail so here's the email
that we've received um and the messaging
light changes
as we get
as we go live but
um
the key thing is that we've got a six
digit code there
and they might have received this email
on their phone doesn't matter what they
have to do is type that code 44141
into this box here
if they get it wrong it'll say you know
they'll code if they didn't receive the
email they might be able to hit resend
verification they'll get another
um
it shouldn't go into their junk folder
we have
various measures in place to stop that
happening but
um
there is a possibility that it might um
and you may need to advise users to look
in the junk folder as i say it shouldn't
happen
so if i've got that code right i click
complete sign up and all that's done is
mark that email address as being
verified it knows that yep i am the
valid owner of that email
and
because it's the first time i've logged
in we've got a registration form to fill
in so
the sign up that i've done so far is is
just determining how i'm going to log in
it doesn't actually tell council
anything about me
so we want to capture some information
and that's what this form is about this
form again is it's configurable so it
might change over time but
um
as it stands it's asking for my my name
you can see the little red asterisks um
next to the fields that they have to
fill in if i miss one it'll and i'll try
and submit the form it'll
tell me which which field i've missed
um
there's a address that we want to
capture
um
this is looking up
all the dresses in new zealand but
if it doesn't find it there's always an
option to click here and they can enter
it manually
uh the email address that i've already
provided is there i can change it at
this point most people won't but if for
example you wanted your login email to
be different
to your profile email that councils are
going to send email to you could put a
different one in there if i do i have to
re-verify it which means entering
another code
also if i've logged in with facebook
for example then we won't have an email
address if i log in with
google or microsoft then the email
address will come in that will be
already verified because it's
um you know has to be to to use it as a
as a gmail or microsoft logan
um but yeah if it's facebook this field
will be blank i have to enter my email
address and i will have to verify again
it's because we're sending emails
accounts or sending emails to this
address so we want to make sure that
someone hasn't put in someone else's
address to spam them
unwanted emails
excuse me
so there's a few other fields i'll put
in my mobile
the advantage of of these fields from a
user's point of view is that they will
default onto any forms that they fill in
in future
um
so the the
mandatory ones are really about council
being able to identify the person some
of these optional ones are more just to
help them when they're filling in forms
so date of birth
etc you don't have to fill in um it is
asking am i an individual or business
that's mandatory um if i choose business
then it's going to ask for some more
details about my
about my business the nzb in number will
be validated against the um the national
register so if i type an invalid one
that will
give me an error and it won't let me
continue until um until there's either
nothing in that field or it's a valid nz
but i'm just going to say i'm an
individual
and i've got to accept the um the terms
of use and privacy policy again
and the recapture
that's the stop you know robots spamming
council but
um
generally it's silent if you're
under certain circumstances if i'm
already logged into google google
provides this recaptcha mechanism so
it's not gonna ask me for anything i'm
not logged into google you tend to get a
check box worst case it will fall back
to
having to
choose a number of images from a grid of
nine or so often you have to identify
street signs or something like that
hopefully it doesn't go to that level
very often in most cases it will just um
leave a bit tick box or it'll be like
this where i don't have to do anything
so i submit my form
and
as long as i've
passed all of the
um
validation on the form
um obviously i was on the way to filling
in a particular form when i logged in
there
um then it'll let me through so what it
what it would normally do is just bounce
you back to the um to the dashboard
you have to um after logging in now
you'll see in the header
instead of the login link that's
disappeared i now have a little circle
and with my initial on it
and if i click on this
the do it online in the header it has a
color purposes one as it displays the 10
most common things that people might
want to do but over on the right here if
i'm logged in it's going to have my name
that's going to have a logout link and
it's also going to have a link to my
profile
now if i click my profile
then we're into this page here and this
is saying
here's the information you provided on
your registration form and if i want to
i can update some of this
so
i might decide to put in
a work phone number or maybe i want to
change my address or what have you
and then i can just submit that
and it will update my profile
um
now the other thing to point out here is
on the left here we've got this
um the security section where it says
manage login methods
and if i click on that
then
this is allowing me to change my login
so
just to be clear that the profile that i
filled in on my registration form and
then i just updated that's about the
information that i've provided to
council to identify myself this is all
about what i use to authenticate to
login
so as before i logged in with
this particular email here
and enter the password i can change my
password here
[Music]
and
the other thing i can do is add
additional logins so if i wanted to
i could add my facebook login
and in that case i would have two ways
to authenticate one is with my email and
password and one is with facebook
so that's quite handy and and sometimes
people will sign up with facebook and
then
at a later point decide they want to
switch to a google
login because they've gone off facebook
or whatever um so you they can come in
here self service and
switch from facebook to google they
could add google once you've got more
than one you get a deactivate link so
you can deactivate ones you don't want
to use
the other thing you can do i've put in
one email say my email address has
changed i can add a different email
and then i'll have two and then i can
deactivate the old one if i wish
and doing things like that adding a new
email it'll go through the same into
your email into your two passwords it'll
do that
verification code again
sending to sending a code to that email
address
so that's um that's quite handy if um if
people are wanting to
change their login they can do it
themselves
without having to contact council um
and
the last thing i want to show you i'm
just going to log out
and it will bounce me back to the
dashboard um i just want to show you
logging in with um
in this case a gmail account so i'm
going to i've already registered with my
google account
and i'm using chrome as my browser i'm
already logged in to google so if i
click log in with google
then
i don't have to enter a password or
anything i'm logged i'm logged in
immediately
this particular account has some
invoices that we're showing
to be paid
but it's that simple and that logging in
with sort of one click
um using my my google or my facebook and
my microsoft account that's
especially handily on phone so
a lot of users will be using smartphones
um their smartphones will already be
logged into either google or facebook if
they've signed up with those accounts
they can do one tap
and they're they're logged in and
authenticated into the portal which is
super handy
okay so that's it in terms of
identity and
logging in and registering
we'll do a second video around some of
the features of the portal around do it
online and my forms and bills and
payments in the next video thanks very
much